>> Thank you all for
your time. So, we
wanted to get a conversation
going between people,
and networking, optics,
hardware, distribute systems.
The main motivation here
is actually very simple.
It's the fact that this
is a time of change.
If you look at
almost any resource
underlined cloud infrastructure,
whether it's compute,
networking inside
the data center or
in the long hall
or different kinds of storage.
The dominant
technology for each of
these resources is approaching
the tail end of its S-curve,
things up looking like a plateau.
For example, if you
think about compute,
the primary metric of interest
is flops per dollar that
we are going to achieve.
Thanks to Moore's law
and Dennard scaling,
we've had a lovely ride
over the past 35 years.
But because of fundamental
physical constraints
on the size of transistors,
the CPU dry voltage and
the number of cores that we
can put on individual sockets,
things seem to the flat line.
Now, this has actually
prompted a lot of
work in our custom accelerators,
things like FPGAs and
GPUs and custom ASICs,
that are getting a lot of
traction in Cloud environments.
You probably heard Mark
talk about the growth
of FPGAs and later
in this session,
you'll hear from Tom and
Samroma about some of
the FPGA innovation happening
for networking workloads.
Similarly, when
you start thinking
about the network
inside data centers,
it relies on electrical switches.
There's an analogous
phenomena that
I'm terming the Moore's Law
for networking.
Essentially,
every couple of years,
switch vendors give us a new
switch generation that
has doubled the bandwidth
but the cost remains
exactly the same.
Now, this is a lovely property
because it allows us
to build faster and faster
networks that can
keep pace with
increasing demand while
keeping the overall network
cost low and constant.
That's actually one
of the assumptions
underlying the Cloud
economic model.
However, things could start
getting tricky very soon.
To understand that, let's
look at this graph again.
Historically, the increase in
switch bandwidth has come from
the fact that we are
able to increase
the speed of the services
at the edge of
the switching ASIC.
The switch vendors
have always used
the non-return to
zero modulation format.
One is encoded as high voltage,
zero as low voltage.
However, the latest
generation of switches is
the first generation
where we've had to
result to higher order modulation
because it's becoming harder and
harder to increase the speed
and the density of those IO pins.
This is like
four level modulation,
which means that
you encode two bits
per symbol but it means that you
have vital SNR requirements
because the levels are
getting closer and closer.
This is a trick that's
hard to play over and
over again because if
you go to eight levels,
your SNR requirements
are even harsher.
So, if you were to step back
and look at network
inside data centers,
the primary metric of
interests is
the gigabits per dollar.
We've had a lovely ride,
but within the next
five or six years,
so by the time we get
to 50 terabits switch
generation beyond that things
could start to look very dodgy.
The same thing applies
to other resources.
If you look at WAN capacity,
we are actually approaching
the Shannon capacity
of individual fibers.
If you go to
the next story session,
you'll hear about
fundamental physical reasons
why we're approaching
capacity limits on hard drives.
Now, if you're
the CTO of a company,
this is a nightmare scenario.
That's a perfect storm.
But for researchers, this
is the perfect opportunity,
because it means that
if we come up with
a new technology,
no matter how disruptive it is,
if it leads to a new growth curve
in terms of these
metrics of interest,
it has a very good chance
of deployment.
I think that's
a really powerful message.
If that's the only message
that you take
away from this talk or
even from this session,
at least I and Yeebo
will be delighted.
So, what I want to do
next is talk to you
about a little bit about
the disruptions happening in
the networking space and tell you
about optical innovations that
we're doing inside the company,
both in research and in
Azure networking to
address these challenges.
So, I'm going to
start with the network
inside the data centers.
If you remember, I told
you about this Moore's law
for networking and
the fact that it has
allowed us to keep
the cost of the network
low and constant.
However, if electrical switches
stop scaling for free,
we'll have an increase
in the cost.
I'll explain the shape of
this curve in a couple
of slides from now.
What's really worrying
is the timing of this.
Because this is expected
to happen around
the same time where
the Cloud traffic
not only continues to
grow but it's pace
actually picks up.
Because of custom
hardware FPGAs, GPUs,
because if new scenarios
like large-scale learning,
which means that we'll be
generating and consuming
a lot more data and
doing it in a power
efficient fashion.
So, this is a big problem for us.
One of the things or
one of the benefits
of working at a place like
Microsoft research is
that we always think
of mediums term
strategic solutions and
long-term disruptive solutions.
I wanted to give you a sense
of those examples of
those solutions in the context
of this problem over
the next few slides.
So, to understand
a solution, let's
look inside the problem
for a second.
So, if you look at
inside the switch,
we have a switching ASIC
that sits on
a substrate or a package
connected by VGA
connectors or IO pins,
a PCB trace and an optical
transceiver that goes from
the bits or the electronic
domains to optical domain.
So, something tiny like this.
Now, it is the speed
and the density of
the IO pins that are causing
the problem because it's
harder and harder to scale.
So, the obvious thing
to do is that well,
why don't we move the optics
closer to the switching ASIC?
Which means that you get rid
of this bottleneck resource
and the switches are
easier to scale.
Now, this is something
that's been discussed
a lot in the optics community,
on the silicon photonics space,
lots of names to it,
we're calling it
In-Package Optics.
So essentially, what
the switch would
look like two
generations from now,
is that you'd have
a switching ASIC,
it would be surrounded by
chiplets comprising
electrical components,
so all the drivers and
all the analog components.
Then the optical
chiplets and what
this would do is it
will take the data
being generated by the ASIC and
modulate light which is then
sent 10's or 100's of meters.
Now, in this case, the chiplet
is made in silicon because
a few reasons to reduce costs and
to make it amenable to
integration with the CMOS ASIC.
What we've started
doing is actually
designing our own chips.
This is a silicon-based chip
designed at a lab.
Is Chi here? He's
a chief designer who
makes the chips for
us that are being
fabricated at external foundries.
Now, one of the key
technical challenges
here is that, well,
to do optical networking,
you need light,
and it's hard to generate
light in silicon.
It's a fundamental problem; it's
an indirect band gap material.
So what we now need to
do is you need to have
disaggregated transceivers
because in a standard
transceiver,
the laser and the modulator
is in the same package.
Whereas in this case, we need
a separate light source,
in this case, which happens to be
shared across all the chiplets.
This is cool because
it means that we
can have a better light source,
we can actually cool it better,
and I think Dan is going to tell
you about more about some of
the implications of
this architectural chain.
Now, this is typically made in
a material like indium phosphide.
Again, we've started
designing our own chips,
and I think this is
an animation that will show you
the different layers of the chip.
It comprises lasers, waveguides,
and other components.
I think it's few millimeters
by few millimeters high, sir?
>> I think it's 12 by
12 millimeters.
>> So 12 millimeters
by 12 millimeters
and that's going to be shared
across the entire switch.
Now, this is an example of
a medium-term solution.
I want to step back
and talk about
the implications of this for
the overall Cloud network cost.
So, historically cost
has been neutral.
We're seeing signs
of disturbances,
but if we are able to deliver on
this in-package optic solution,
we'd be able to extend
the cost neutrality of
switches for the next
five to six years.
Which is great, because it
means that the
world's not ending.
But at some point,
we'll run into the actual
physical constraints
on the number of
fibers that we can
align at the edge of
the switching ASIC,
which means that
we'll have to have
complex solutions and an increase
in overall network cost.
At some point, we'll run into
the actual CMOS scaling limit,
whereby you cannot put
more transistors onto
the switching ASIC,
which means that we'll
have multiple ASICs on
the same dye inside each pack
inside each switch,
which in turn means
an increase in complexity
and an increase in cost
for every network
generation thereafter.
That's the nightmare scenario for
us, and that's where we really,
really come in,
the long-term opportunity
for optics and photonics.
So what we really want to do is
actually look at
these topologies,
and instead of using
electrical packet switches,
replace them with
optical circuit switches,
something that's been
thought a lot about in
the optics community and
in the network community.
Now, one of the
advantages of moving
away from CMOS
components is that you
can develop
technologies that have
a much higher relics and you
can have a much flatter topology.
This means that they can offer
better performance per dollar
because there are
fewer transceivers
and fewer switches
in the network.
Because there's no buffering
inside the network,
we can offer very low and
very predictable latency,
and that predictability is really
important for the kinds of
application scenarios that we
expect to double up in
the Cloud owner experience.
Finally, because we don't
have dependency on CMOS,
this can actually be
a long-lasting solution.
So this is actually
motivated us over
the past couple of years
as a team to develop
a research prototype that shows
the basic feasibility of
achieving off very fast
optical switching,
nanoseconds switching,
so that we can match
the performance of
electrical packet switches.
So stuff that done a lot in
the optics community but this is
now taking a building
a real system artifact.
Now, I do want to point out
that there's a big difference
in a circuit-switched
architecture
and a packet-switched
architecture.
So, there's a long, long way
to go to take this from up,
research for a tie
with a bunch of
virus back in Cambridge to
something that can connect
an actual data center
and run real applications.
So I just want to check
the QB expectations and check,
but the IPO technology gives us
the space to four to five years
needed to do that.
So, I want to change tack
now quickly and move outside
the data center and give you
another example of this hardware,
software, network
optics co-design.
So, about five years ago,
we used to build mega
data centers facilities,
a few 100,000 servers,
big land, lots of power,
but increasingly we're finding
it hard to find the land,
and the power, and space
for such mega facilities.
So over the past couple of years,
we move to the
regional architecture,
where we have many
medium-sized data centers,
about 100,000 servers in
the same metro region,
so 80 kilometers connected
by a regional hub.
Now, let's think about
the implications
of this for the underlying
network architecture.
So, in a traditional mega
data center we
have the standard plus topology,
in this case, I'm
showing four levels.
In all our data centers we
use optical cables
outside the rack,
which means that every
switch port needs
a transceiver that are shown
earlier to do the
optoelectronic conversion,
and this is a great transceiver.
So transmits over
a single wavelength.
When we do transmission
over the long haul,
so when you're going
thousands of kilometers,
we need a colored transceiver
which is massive
power hungry and rather heavy,
so I can keep this too long.
On the other hand,
when you move to
the regional architecture,
what happens is that well, yes,
you're essentially
taking this build block
and doing smaller chunks,
but your regional link,
the one in the red, is
actually 80 kilometers.
So what this means is that, yes,
we can use great transceivers
inside the data centers,
but now we have to use
colored power, expensive,
hungry transceivers both on
the van on the regional links.
This is a nightmare if you
were to do this for power,
and cost, and space,
and all these reasons.
So, what the Azure
networking team did
is they actually went out and
designed their own transceivers
that are customized for
the regional environment.
This is a colored
transceiver that
can operate over 80 kilometers.
You can see it's
exactly the same form factor as
the great transceiver that we
use inside the data center.
Essentially, the trick
is to customize the DSP,
to customize the FEC
for the particular
scenario of interest.
If the light's not going
tens of thousands of kilometers,
why would we do chromatic
dispersion for that distance?
So, those are
the kinds of designing
for our scenarios that led
to this innovation and
this was co-design both
inside the company and
working with Inphi,
who manufactures
these transceivers,
and these are being
deployed in our
data centers for the past year.
So, the reason I chose
these two examples is to give
you a sense of our thinking,
innovation by combining
optics with networking,
distributed systems,
architecture, and hardware.
We genuinely believe that to
develop the next generation
of Cloud infrastructure,
we will have to innovate
across the stack,
and we can do this because
as a Cloud operator,
we own and operate
the entire stack.
As I showed you, we are
developing our own custom chips,
we are building
optical components.
We have designed
and are deploying
our own transceivers
and our own switches,
and as you'll hear,
we already have our NICs.
So we can deploy things on
the stack on the NIC or
the sellers themselves,
which allows us to
innovate across the stack.
That's something that we're
doing both in our work but
also in all our collaborations
with academic collaborators.
For example, the work
that we're doing with
Dan and many of you in this room.
So, that's the message
I wanted to get across.
Thank you for your
time. I think I'm
running out of time,
so thanks again.
>> Do you have time
for one more question?
>> Yeah.
>> So, real fast.
You didn't say anything
about efficient use of
the optical network but even
with 100 gigabits right now,
we're seeing the people
doing small rights
and not many of the data lanes
on this sort of wide data
path are really occupied.
So you've got, say 10 data lane
66 bits each and you've got
one bite of good data there,
maybe 60 bytes of headers
and the rest is just empty.
What can be done at that layer?
>> That's a very good question.
I'll give you two short answer
to that question,
you can apply that question in
the van scenario where
efficiency is very
important and you really
need to think about
software-defined primitives
to achieve that.
I think your question was
more in the intra-DC context.
One of the interesting
things about
the intra-DC context is
that things like
the 60-byte header
or the 40-byte header come from
scenarios if we are limited
to legacy protocols.
If we control things
like the NIC and
the underlying network,
in many customized scenarios
like RDMA clusters,
I would argue we should
just go to customize
protocols that produce
a lot of this already.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yeah, I completely agree.
I think in that sense
you really need
a decoupling of the data
plane and the control plane
would which allow you
to make those changes.
Yes, I completely
agree on that one.
Do we have one question?
>> Maybe that's bringing
the question [inaudible].
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, all right.
So, let's thanks Sidhash again.
>> Thank you.
>> The next speaker
is Tom Anderson.
I believe most of you
already know him,
but here's a short description.
Tom Anderson's the chair in
a [inaudible] and school for
computer science
engineering at the UW.
His research interests
span all aspects of
building prod code robust and
efficient computer systems.
So, he's a member of
National Academy of Engineering
and we know of multiple
lifetime achievement awards.
>> Great and I
think actually this
will be this great counterpoint.
I'm actually at essence
an operating systems person
and many of the things
that have been driving
our research over time is
just this recognition that
we are in the Cloud setting
spending or particularly for
really key applications spending
huge amounts of time just
doing these repetitive operations
in the operating system.
What's clear about
the hardware technology trends
are that everything that
can be re-implemented,
everything that's
of high capacity,
the things that you're doing
all the time are going
to be re-implemented
hardware just
you can't afford to do
just general-purpose processing
for things that you're
doing many, many times.
You can see this with TPUs
but you're also going to see
this on networking and
for operating systems.
So, essentially the argument
that I'm going to
try to make here,
what we've been looking at
is on the protocol stack,
but more broadly
I think one could
ask this question more
generally about
operating systems in general.
I'm going to come down
from the application side
rather than up from what
we can do in hardware.
So, one of the things that's
really characteristic
of these applications is a lot of
the applications people actually
run on data centers is that
large amounts of a very
fine-grained communication
partly just because
as you start to
spread applications out over
more and more nodes because
you need more and more nodes
because Dennard scaling
isn't doing it for you.
Now, your communication
granularity goes down
and interesting dataset
that somebody in
the SIGCOMM community collected
all of the RPCs inside of
the Google data center
over a period of time that
the median size of that
was only 300 bytes.
So, generally you're doing
single packet transfers
between nodes.
You still want
the semantics of TCP,
so that is reliable
in order delivery.
It's many-to-many,
so what do you like
the applications that this tries
for are key-value
stores, databases,
distributed analytics, and that
you're pushing performance
limits on those,
and then scaling up as you go.
So, the question is how
you can deal with this.
So, on the software
processing side,
Linux, even if you ignore
the VM layer because you're going
to say catapult will take
care of that for you.
On the VM side or
on the TCP side,
you're spending
huge amounts of time doing
just regular processing if you're
trying to do through
Linux about three and a half
microseconds per packet,
and then single core performance
it's not going to bail you out,
so you could try to
parallelize this that
has tried to run many,
many connections over
many, many cores,
but potentially it's
going to just end up
burning lots of power and
spending a lot of effort,
a lot of cost and
time doing things that you
don't really need to do.
So, there are lots of
proposed solutions to this.
Probably, everybody in the room,
but I know many of these so
one of them is kernel bypass,
so DPDK or things like that.
The challenge though is that
what you want is something that's
going to give you a
policy enforcement,
that is if you're in
a multi-tenant data center
you also need to worry about,
well what are these
applications actually doing
and can you trust them
is it going to be the case
that they're going to obey,
congestion control,
your behavior of
your network is going to
depend on n Host behavior.
So, you need something
that's going to
give you policy enforcement.
Some people are deploying
a SmartNICs or NIC CPU
arrays and I should
say actually there's
this really nice paper from
MSR that Sambra's possibly
going to talk about,
I'm not sure, that actually
goes through essentially a
lot of the same arguments
and that appeared at less than
STI 18 and actually
makes all of the same
arguments that we would make.
If you try to put on your Nick
essentially CPU arrays,
the challenge for
that is there is
this complicated thing as
you scale out
the number of CPUs or
doing your TCP
processing that you
have this complex
assignment problem of
that to the CPU array and
limited per flow performance,
that is if you potentially want
really high bandwidth for
a given individual flow and it's
also relatively expensive
to go build those.
RDMA is the one that the research
community spending
most of their time on.
In fact, most of
the stuff that I'm
going to talk about
here is essentially
trying to understand
how you would
build a more flexible
RDMA engine.
RDMA, the API is fine
for some things,
but certainly for
these small-scale
single packet RPC communication
as a protocol,
writing or reading from
memory isn't necessarily,
but natural thing
that you would do if
you wanted to build
a really fast RPC system,
and then the hardware for RDMA
actually bundles not so well
with the congestion
control protocols
that you would actually
want to use in practice,
and so some people had also
done TCP offload engine
to be an example,
you need arguments are going to
make towards a protocol agility.
Ultimately, if I integrate
over that whole set I
think what you want is
the traditional operating
system functionality
that is the feature set
of operating systems,
which is multi-tenant isolation,
the ability to say that
the behavior of
applications doesn't affect
other applications and at
the same time hardware
assist that has
some way of doing a flexible
reconfigurable architecture,
so that you can then change
your protocols as you need them,
do you policy
compliance as you want,
scale up connections to
really large numbers
of connections,
CPU efficiency in
the common case and
performance efficiency,
so essentially you
can think of you want
the flexibility side to be
able to do whatever you
want and at the other
side be able to
handle the stuff at
the speeds that you want to
handle them without having to
do a huge amount and
I'm going to make
this argument independently of
the FPGA versus VLSI argument.
Microsoft has done
perspective on that
which is FPGAs are the feature,
but in some ways
the argument I'm going
to make here is going
to be independent of that,
so you can think of
this hardware assist
at multiple levels.
So, one layer and
the keynote talked about
some extent which
Microsoft is already
deployed widely
demonstrated this.
If you're only asking about
the packet processing
at the VM layer that is
creating a virtual network
that makes the virtual
machine look like,
"Oh, okay, I've got
my own little land
here that I'm going to be
able to communicate with."
That set of work is
pretty regular and
actually pretty demonstrable that
you can move that onto hardware.
What I'm going to end
up talking about is
a harder problem which is, "Okay,
now once you've gotten these
packets to the virtual
machine," the virtual machines
now spending almost
all of its time doing
TCP packet processing in
the virtual machine than
the guest operating system,
so that's inefficient from
the customer perspective.
It's like why was I burning
all the CPU time for that.
So, can you take and try to
do flexible hardware
acceleration inside the VM,
so how you TCP packet
processing in hardware,
and then you could ask
a similar question about
the application level processing,
so you're handing this
off to an application,
it's also doing
essentially layer seven
packet processing,
how do you want to
try to optimize that.
This whole set of things
can actually be handled in
this thing that I'm going
to talk called FlexNIC,
but it's just a model for how
you would do
the programming for it.
Then, I'm also going to talk
a little bit about how you
could do this flexibility at
network switches and
in general where
this is going to tie in
with the optical side is
where you do have congestion
that is where you
have large amounts of
communication coming
in generally at
the top of rack
switch or whatever.
You are going to need
to be able to do
something on the level
of trying to do
resource allocation
in some fashion
largely in the
programmable space.
Okay, the overarching lesson
here is going to
be the common case packet
handling is systolic,
which is to say that
individual packet
that the steps that
you're taking to do
packet processing
is regularizable
and that can be pipelined
not just packet to packet,
but even within a packet
that you can do
regular communication and
as a consequence of that,
that you will end
up being able to do
large amounts of
high bandwidth operation.
Even on a single flow
because you're
pipelining individual
stages of computation.
I'll come back to
this point that I
made earlier, which is that,
anything that can be regularized,
and you're spending
a lot of time on,
will eventually be
built into hardware.
It's just how the economics
of data center's going to work.
So now, the question is,
how you can go about this?
This will happen both
on NICs and switches.
Okay. So, the programming
model we started
with is, it's usually
reconfigurable.
Multi-stage pipelines are not
the only people
working in the space.
You take this packet
stream coming in,
you have a programmable parser
that goes through some number
of stages of computation.
These computational stages
are protocol agnostic.
You can run essentially
about a terabit per
second in a single pipeline,
Barefoot's demonstrated that.
So, from a NIC perspective,
that is from an in-house
perspective, that's pretty good.
That'll carry you pretty far.
The idea is going to have
predictable performance.
The stages all
executed in parallel.
You can think of essentially,
each successive packet,
it goes through the stage
in the sequence.
As a consequence, from
a single flow perspective,
you're still processing
everything in order,
as opposed to
spreading it out over
multiple pipelines
or multiple CPUs,
which you might be doing
in a smartNIC operation.
Then, you're having to make
sure that all of the packets for
given flow go through
the same sequence,
or on the same processor,
just for this kind of
state management
ordering constraints.
Okay. So, what are
these match action systems do?
You can think of them
the kind of the simple cases,
that they can steer packets,
they can initiate DMA,
trigger replies, or whatever.
This is an application
that's trying
to write on a particular port,
then what I should
do with this is to
hash it to a particular core,
and then DMA to a cue
or something like that.
Because they're regular, again,
in a systolic model,
you don't want loops.
There's no complicated
arithmetic.
You have to be careful about
what you're doing with state.
You can have an arbitrary
number of stages.
It's not programming the way
we would normally think of it,
rather you're programming
for hardware.
So, we designed a part of
this from a NIC perspective,
how you would actually
make this work.
For the NIC actually has
multiple pipelines coming in.
So, it has data coming
in for received data,
that is, you're having
to do some set of
pipeline stages for packets
that arriving from the network.
Similarly, the host itself is
also delivering
packets into the NIC.
So, we have some pipeline
for handling that.
There's a transmit pipeline
that actually send data out.
There's also a pipeline
to try to do,
essentially programmable
NIC behavior.
You can imagine if
you were to try to
decompose what happens
on an RDMA packet,
if that was your protocol
that you were trying
to implement?
What happens on an RDMA packet
is essentially demux,
you're parsing the packet,
and then demuxing
on an element of
the packet that
tell the DMA engine
to do a particular operation.
That step is something that's
pretty similar to what
a TCP packet does when
you arrive, like,
"Okay, I'm going to
get this packet in,
and I want to decide which
Q this is going to go into
based on the port number."
Then, based on that, and
maybe the sequence
number in the packet,
and then that's going to tell
me where to go from there.
So, what this then
allows me to do is,
to do this transform
these packets
efficiently in software
DMA directly in and out of
application data structure.
So, it looks like it
has all the same benefits
that RDMA has,
and then send acknowledgement
out on the NIC.
But potentially, you can
implement TCP with it.
So, if you look at
what TCP is doing,
it's got a lot going on.
You're opening,
closing connections,
you've got locking on socket API,
you've got IP routing
or firewalls like
congestion control,
very complicated connections.
They often in the kernel,
if you look at the kernel code.
You're doing multiple steps,
you're chasing data structures,
you're doing pointer
chasing a lot.
It's like, "Oh, okay,
how's this going to end
up working in this kind
of systolic model?"
The model we've taken is one
that we've taken
essentially split out
the operating system code into
a fast path that's regularizable,
and then a slow
path for everything
that's not regularizable.
Then, hopefully you
could say, "Oh, okay,
the slow path just
handles offline."
So, you can think
essentially of the
fast path doing all of
the normal operations you
would do on every data packet,
generating data segments,
applying rate limits,
and so forth.
Collecting congestion
statistics, all of these,
ending up running
on the NIC itself.
Then, the slow path
running in the kernel
that handles essentially all of
the other connection or
control plane operations.
Then, the application ends up
doing some additional
amount of work.
One of the aspects of
this is to say that
you're splitting up
congestion control in a way
that splits the work,
so that instead of
thinking that you're
doing congestion
control every packet,
you can think that you're doing
it on a round-trip basis.
So, collecting information
on the data path,
and then using it on
a background basis
to enforce congestion control.
But, that's actually
sufficient for
implementing the protocols
that we have.
So, this is the kind
of performance graph,
all end up leaving here,
which is essentially
how well this can do.
This is Linux here,
scaling up to 16 core
is not very well.
Then, a software implementation
of what I've just described,
which actually does enforce
congestion control compared
to software version
of just the DDPA TCP version
that doesn't enforce
congestion control.
They actually do reasonably well,
and then it's a hardware version
is that line over there.
All of this is actually just
emulated rather than other.
You can actually think
about a bunch of
these issues also happening
inside of the network itself,
so switches themselves
can also be programmable.
You can ask this question of
what can we do inside
of the network
using a reprogrammable hardware
to do different things?
One of the things that
we've been looking at is to
do essentially
approximate fair queuing.
So, fair queuing is
one of these things,
the kind of longstanding,
maybe 30, 40 years ago,
I'm not actually sure
exactly when it was.
>> Thirty.
>> Thirty? Thirty
years ago, okay.
So, I dated from
almost before I graduated
from grad school.
So, that's how long ago it was.
But, the idea is that,
you get isolation that is
more predictable behavior out
of your network if
you're able to say
that if you're queuing
discipline and how you
handle packets inside
of the network
at a base for queuing.
The challenge for it is that,
it's really difficult to
implement these things
in any kind of fashion.
This is just an animation of what
happens as you go
about doing this.
In order to get
fair queuing to work,
I'll just go forward from this.
The different pieces, you need to
have a sorted packet buffer,
you need to store an update
per flow counters,
you need to track global state
that updates on every packet,
and all of that ends up like,
"Okay, how are you
going to end up
implementing that
multi-gigabit speeds,
or you're talking about
trying to implement
it at many gigabits?"
So, the argument is that,
you could potentially
use this kind of
reconfigurable match
action model to
simulate fair queuing or
approximate fair queuing.
I'm not going to actually
do the example here,
but I'll just skip by it.
But the idea is, basically,
to use multiple queues to try
to approximate the behavior,
store approximate per flow
counters and tables,
and so forth.
So, there's a lot of research
that people are doing in terms of
trying to understand
what you can do
with re-programmable switches.
The outcome of this
ends up being,
so this table here,
this is actually
flows size on the x-axis,
and then normalized completion
time on the y-axis,
so smaller is better.
Then, AFQ, which
is the blue line.
So, as you get bigger flows,
then, of course, it takes
longer to complete.
But, one of the things
that you end up seeing is,
even for things like DCTCP,
which is kind of the best
known congestion control
protocol for data centers,
you can do better
as a consequence of
having more intelligence
happening inside of the switch.
Okay, and I'll just
leave it there.
>> Thank you.
Any questions? Cool.
Though I have one.
>> Okay.
>> So you talked about Flex TCP.
So maybe I missed it.
Ideally, totally
kernel bypass technique or is
it to as they're rating
their kernel stack
using the hardware?
>> The enforcement,
and you can think of
as the equivalent of virtue.
I think, probably,
the best analogy
for this is there was a period
about 40 or 50 years ago,
where we decided that
what we needed to do
for multiprogramming was to
have virtual memory hardware.
There was a period
where people didn't
know what that virtual
memory hardware look like.
Like what exactly were
the obstructions?
What we ended up with was
this notion of having essentially
table-driven enforcement
mechanism that's
controlled by the
operating system kernel.
That model is essentially
the one that we're
moving towards,
which is we're trying
to come up with
some new set of constraints,
some new model for how
operating systems are going
to interact with networks.
That going to be
these control plans
operating in the kernel,
that's the enforcement
mechanism that says,
"Here's how much bandwidth
you're going to get
on a particular flow.
These are the logic of what
you're able to do from
an application perspective."
Then, everything else,
what the application
actually does itself
is all done at full speed.
So what VM hardware does
essentially is to say,
"Look, in the normal case,
you're executing at
the full speed of
the hardware even
though I'm providing
this protection layer with
some hardware assist."
The question that we're
ending up trying
to figure out is,
what is that hardware
assist that you need to
be able to implement
this at full speed?
>> Okay. All, right. Yeah.
>> Okay. Over there,
we have someone.
>> Oh, sorry. Kahn, did you want?
>> Let me pass the microphone.
>> I have the microphone.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'll ask
my question anyway.
So, a lot of dialogue
about RDMA centers
on NIC use of resources that
are really living in the OS,
such as the page table entries,
and actually the
specific DMA mappings,
and then the DMA
permissions records
which are all tables
within the stricts to
exceed the amount of SRAM
available and most of
these NICs don't have time to go
off to DRAM on an average packet.
Do you have an opinion on all
of that, where is it trending?
>> Yes. Some person,
so if you want to
start coming up.
There was a really nice, again,
this NSDI paper of looking
at how they map catapult.
They have a two level
connection state model
where the SRAM is for
the active connections
and then they have
a DRAM backup for other ones.
I think, once you
start to think that
your operating system is managing
hundreds of thousands of packets,
you're needing to do some kind
of a two-stage model for it.
So, I think, that also is
a really interesting
question of, well,
if everybody is actively using
tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of
packet of connections
simultaneously,
then does this kind of
caching model work,
and how do you make that work?
Now, that upside is that
even if you have to
fetch your your connection state
in from DRAM to do some work,
as long as it's
relatively compact,
the thing that you might be
doing over time would be
some regular amount of
operation that the amount of time
that a connection is actually
actively using the NIC is
going to be relatively small.
So, the only number of
active connections you might be
doing inside of the NIC at
any point in time
might not be large.
There are also
large amounts of like
just regular protocol
issues that come
from trying to run
large numbers of
connections simultaneously,
like TCB is just basically broken
for once you get above
a thousand connections.
We ran a really simple
tests that just
doing simple RPCs between
two nodes with
a thousand connections,
and Linux will literally
starve connections,
like, "Okay, is that
the best we can do?
Hopefully not." Okay. Great.
>> It's time for a last question.
>> Oh, our last question.
>> This is just a quick
question. What you're proposing
in FlexNICs [inaudible] P4,
are you trying to use
the same programming abstraction
of P4 at the host site?
>> So, you can think of
it as very similar to P4.
I think the difference
is P4 doesn't
really have a model for
how to program DMA.
So, we added essentially it's
P4 plus the kind of
DMA programming.
>> Okay. Let's thank Tom again.
The next speaker is
Sambrahma Mundkur.
She is a technical lead
in Azure networking,
working in the area of
Azure IT networking.
So, in Microsoft, she
has primary work on
network offloading
technologies especially
in the area of
network virtualization,
such as virtual machine cues,
single route SIoT and
generic pro table offloading.
>> Thank you. Hi, like he
said, my name is Sambrahma.
I'm a tech lead in
Azure networking.
I specifically work in
the Host Net Working Group.
For the last couple of years,
what we've been working on is to
offload the software
stack that we
have in the Azure hosts
to an FPG SmartNIC,
and deploying this entirely
in our Azure data centers,
and seeing great benefits
out of it in performance and
latency through put per
packets per second, etc.
So, I'll go into
some of the details
about how we went about
implementing this.
So, the agenda for my talk will
be a little bit about
the Azure background.
How the problems that
we have in scale,
and the SDN stack,
the weights implemented
today in the software stack,
and what are some of the
challenges we face around
that in packet processing
at a per packet level
in the host.
We'll also talk about
what other considerations
we employ to
determine that FPG SmartNIC is
the right choice for
us to go forward,
and then I'll go into
some of the details of
what the architecture and
the design of the SmartNIC.
Then, we have a lot
of lessons learned
because this is pretty
much the first time
where we are deploying at
such a scale software and
hardware project coexistence,
and deploying hardware at
such a scale to be
able to debug it,
monitor it, have alerts,
and add an agile wave
which is like
our cornerstone of
Azure and networking.
So, this is the
generic slide that we
use for the Azure services.
So, we have at the bottom
most layer the infrastructure
service which
includes our storage,
compute, networking, et cetera.
On top of it, we have
the data services and
providing the app services
like Azure ML,
analytics, et cetera.
So, Azure and networking has
come a long way since it
was first deployed
in terms of compute.
We have started from
like 10K or 100K of
VMs and now we're at millions
of virtual machines.
Azure storage has
seen the same rate of
growth as well as
the networking where
we're seeing from terabytes
of data to petabytes today.
So, this is a generic
marketing slide
that we use and we see
at what rate the Azure is
growing on a day-to-day
basis literally.
We have to have support for
all the Linux VMs because most of
the virtual machines that
are out there are Linux VMs.
We see a great growth in
terms of the deployment,
onboarding of new customers,
and the different kinds of
features and requirements that
we have in terms of Azure
and networking
specifically as well.
So, that would show us like
the agility that we may
need to maintain because lot of
the features that we add
are customer-driven,
either through issues
that they face
or the new features
that they need
to move from their current model
on-prem network to
the Azure network.
So, other ways to
think about scale.
It's not just about deploying
a service or deploying a feature,
it's about how do
we handle failures,
how do we detect, monitor,
and is a continuous feedback
loop that we need to be in.
Believe me, we often get
our on-call rotations,
and it's not pretty
to live through
a one week of
an on-call rotation,
because if you don't
have a backup of knowing
how to automate this detection
of heart failures like switch,
link, node failures, the
crashing of any
software components
in the nodes, et cetera,
at such a large scale,
it's literally impossible
to do manually or
even not having
a super sophisticated
automated solution for that.
So, another customer goal
would be to actually,
one is detection of these
failures and mitigation of it.
So, most likely,
we would prefer to
know about an issue before
a customer even notices it.
So, we need to have
the automation in
place to detect these conditions
that are going on,
some heart failures, and
be able to mitigate it,
which would be like a service
heal the virtual machine to
a different node or in our case,
for example, switch
back from let's say,
if the hardware is misbehaving,
switch back to the software
path et cetera.
Then, we always have the problem
of soft failures which
are not obvious.
Obviously, if the link is
down between two switches,
it's easy to detect, easy to fix.
But if there are
soft failures that
we see very often is like
one in 100 packets is getting
corrupted by one extra byte
or something like that.
Though sometimes I've
seen even in practice,
those go unnoticed
until, for example,
in our case when we offloaded
this flow to an FPGA,
the FPGA was adding an extra
32 bytes at the end
of the packet.
That went unnoticed until
some TLS type of
checksum was happening,
and then at
the customer endpoint,
they would see an effect of this.
So, how do we detect
this kind of failures?
A lot of issues that
we see are in latency.
So, generally, everything
is working fine.
Occasionally, the latency
peaks at 50 milliseconds
or something like that in
a TCP type of operation.
So how do we detect that?
How do we monitor
that at that scale?
That's also very important.
So, I think again,
I'm stressing the automation
is the key for all this.
The other thing is
the IaaS customers,
they are highly intolerant to
any virtual machine downtime
or any networking downtime.
So, whenever we have
to service any of
our components and we have a lot
of components
including in the host,
in the washing machine,
in the host,
and now in the
hardware et cetera,
the serviceability is the key.
We cannot afford to bring down
the host, we cannot reboot,
so we try to update
all our components
reboot lessly except for
the Os which also we tried to do
it in such a fashion that the
downtime is extremely less.
Any networking components being
updated or being serviced
need to guarantee that
we do not see a network outage
to the virtual machine
and we try our best to actually
keep the TCP connections alive
so that's the goal of it.
Basically, the VM should not
really be able to see
a TCP connection drop.
So, the key to this
is performance.
Everything is measured
at four to five nines
and on a customer basis which
includes the performance,
the network performance,
the host performance,
the VM availability
whether they should
not suffer any downtime
and the serviceability
of all our components.
So, how do we achieve
SDN in Azure?
So, today, what we do is what
we call is the host SDN.
So, our data Plane
runs in the host,
we have distributed controllers
that are running
across the region.
So, for example, the SLB
has original SLB manager.
For any vignette programming,
there is a regional
network manager,
et cetera that is per region.
We have controllers running
at each of the hosts.
So, any of the configuration
that comes along from
the management plane which
is using the rest API
like a portal or CLI,
however, the deployment occurs
for the virtual machine,
that comes to the regional
network manager eventually and
those policies are programmed
to upper host level.
So, the controller on
the host programs,
our virtual switch that
runs in the host and
the data plane in
the virtual switch is which
applies the policies.
So, obviously, then you have
this data plane needs to
apply the flow policy to
millions of VMs and that's
only achievable because
we are handling it
at the host level for
whatever number of VMs that
are running on the host.
So, this is a diagram
of our software stack,
this runs in each of the host.
So, we have the
virtual machines hosted
on the Azure node or
the host as we call it.
So, before a hardware
acceleration,
what is presented to
the virtual machine
is a synthetic NIC
or a software NIC.
Any packet that needs
to come in and out of
the VM is always going
through the software
stack in the VM,
that goes to the hypervisor,
to the host and in the host
we have what we call
as a VMSwitch which is
a layer two switch
which basically
is really a delivery mechanism
in and out of the VM.
All the policies that I told that
get applied to the controllers,
the controller programs
using a VFP API which is
a simple match action table API.
So, the controllers program
the VFP with that information.
So, like I said, there
could be different kinds
of controllers like something
for load balancing,
something for ravine it customer,
address to the provider,
address mapping,
ACLs, metering et cetera.
So, each of the controllers can
program their own rules and
those go into different layers of
VFP and they're
independent of each other.
So, if you were to
add a new feature,
we could have
a new layer and none of
the other controllers
would have to
change any of their policy.
So, in VFP, what would
happen is so let's take
an example of a packet
being transmitted from the VM
that would land from the VM
over what we call as
a virtual machine bus to
the host from the hypervisor.
In the host when it
hits the VMSwitch,
VFP is built as
an extension to VMSwitch.
So, originally when
we started Azure,
all of the policy enforcement
was done as part of VMSwitch.
Then, due to different
constraints because
the VMSwitch update requires
a reboot et cetera,
so we went with
this model of having
a pluggable virtual filtering
platform within VMSwitch.
So, every packet
that VMSwitch sees,
in inbound and outbound
path is routed through VFP.
VFP is the one that is the brains
of the host SDN on the host.
So, it applies all the policies,
it goes through the layers.
For example, on an
outbound packet,
it would go through
the ACL layer,
modify the packet based
on the configuration,
go to the VNET layer, modify
that packet let's say
map the CA to the PA.
This might also need
some communication to
the regional control plane.
For example, you might not have
the mapping of this
destination VM,
you might need to wait for
that configuration to
come back and then apply
that change to that packet
and then go to
the SLB layer so
any VIP to DIP mapping
would occur there.
So, this processing allows us to
do multiple layers independent
of different kinds of
controllers programming it.
Then we go one step further than
this that once this packet
goes through it,
if you see a connection
setup packet like
in the case of TCP
being the Syn packet,
you know that this is
a packet and these are
the flow ID for
this packet and the end result
is always going to be the same.
So, ACL, VNET, SLB
the NAT layer combine
it and what is the final action
that is called as
a transposition,
we can save that information
so that you don't have to go to
the individual layers after
the connection setup is done.
So, we call this
technology call as
a Unified Flow which is
actually the basis for
offloading to
the accelerated links.
So, this again explains
how we would go through
the layering occur
both in the inbound
and outbound so the VFP
is also the forwarder.
So once, it does
the outbound processing
for a packet, it
forwards a packet,
it determines a target
and then does
the inbound processing based
on the rules set
up for that port.
So, the target could either
be another VM on
the same host for example,
if they were do VM to VM and
we're seeing more of this in
particular requirements or
it could be another VM on
a VNET in Azure within
the region or another region or
it could be some
internet endpoint.
So, it doesn't matter.
Basically, the VFP is just
doing a purport
policy application
on inbound and outbound.
So, this just shows you
the flow of a packet.
So, for example, the ACLS
would be applied,
the different action is
specified for that layer,
for example, drops
certain packets
with 10.416 address et cetera.
Then the action at
the load balancer layer
and then the VNET mapping
would occur at the end layer.
So, what do we see as
challenges in this?
This works fine at 1G, at 10G,
it works fine, but what
do we see as challenges?
As the networking
speed increases,
there are more and more packets
being generated,
but there's not enough CPU
to handle this load.
What are the options for us?
So, we would prefer to
offload this to hardware,
but when we offload it
to hardware using ASICs,
you are having a one or two years
of cycle to update the ASICs.
It might not be sufficient,
what are the features available
in the ASICs, et cetera.
So, we decided to look at
FPGAs to solve this problem.
So, what we have is today,
we'd still have the ASIC NIC
that provides the access
to the virtual machine.
There is a technology
called Single-Root
IO Virtualization which allows
the virtual functions or PC
virtual function to
be exposed to the VM.
So, the packets from the VM can
directly access the
network to and from it.
But if it did that,
then it will be
bypassing the host and
there would be nobody
applying the policies.
So, we go with this bump
in the wire model
that the delivery of the
packets and reception of
the packets from
the VM still occurs
on the virtual function
and the existing NIC.
Any of the offloads that the NIC
can provide for example,
receives site scaling
like CPU steering,
task offloads like
checksum, et cetera,
or lots of offload, that can
still occur at that NIC,
but the policy application
on a per packet basis
occurs on an FPGA that's
programmed by RVFP.
We use this API
called the GFP API
which converts the unified flow
that we talked about in
the VFP to the settings
basically what
the FPG understands.
These are some of
the measurements
that we got from running
regular open-source tools like
iPerf and so forth
and you see I'll just
go quickly over this.
Like you see the compute D series
gets up to 25G and we see
improvements in
the latency especially
because we have SR-IOV totally
bypass the whole stack.
So, we see per packet
per second improvement,
and then you
obviously also reduce
jitter because you don't have
any software issues of getting
descheduled by hypervisor to
run VM processing et cetera.
So, this gives us more cores
for the VM processing
offloads all the network
to the hardware.
Then, since the VM can get
near native performance,
we can also include
other workloads that needed
that kind of performance.
So, this is an example of
what, on the left side,
you have how the packets
transmission and
reception looks like in
the case where it's being
processed by the software.
So, anything coming out of
the VM goes to
the virtual switch,
does the processing, then goes
out of the physical layer.
But in the case of
accelerated networking,
it just goes to
the network card and
directly out of
the TOR and beyond.
So, this is an example of how
the GFT actually
does the processing.
So, like I said, the controllers
program VFP as of today,
there's no change over there.
VFP still needs to
be there in the path
of what we call as
Exception Packets which is
the connection setup packets,
and for TCP it is
SYN, SYN-ACK packets.
For UDP, it's the first
packet that we see.
So, we are right now
offloading just TCP and UDP,
and potentially we would
do RDMA flows as well.
So, like I said,
the unified flow gets created in
the VFP when it does
receive the first packet,
so it goes through the slope out
processing in across each layers,
generates this unified
flow which is,
this is a flow and
this is the action,
and that is what it
configures to the GFT.
So, GFT is the engine running
inside the FPGA SmartNIC.
So, when FPGA receives
this packet from the VM,
let's say an outbound packet,
it goes through its table,
there's a multi-layer
hash table lookup.
So, like we were seeing
on the SRAM and then,
we have an L1 cache and
you don't find the packet,
go to the DRAM lookup that,
and if you don't find that packet
or a flow for
that particular packet,
that's tagged as
an exception packet and
sent to the whole stack
for VFP to process.
If it does find a packet which is
when VFP offloads this flow,
then it does the
transformation itself,
bypasses the stack, and
sends it out on the TOR.
Similarly, if you
receive a packet,
the same mechanism happens,
but when it will indicate
the packet to the ASIC NIC
which is using the SR-IOV
and directly indicating
the packet to VM,
again we bypass the host.
Off the key thing for
this is serviceability.
So, serviceability is a key is
because we need to be
able to update any of
the components without any kind
of downtime for the VM,
because we have to- so,
I have just one minute,
so I'll quickly go over
some of the lessons we
learned in this area as well.
So, one of that is basically,
if the VM cannot suffer downtime,
then we need to have a failover,
simple failover from
the hardware to
the software part when any of
the key components
are being serviced.
So, that was one of
the key things that we did
as part of the initial design
because we also
need a service because
the whole idea of using
FPGA is to be innovate
as fast as we can
which means our goal
is to service
the entire stack every month
in the spring fashion, right?
So, some of the lessons that
we learned is I would say,
the most important is
monitoring is really the key.
It's not in
my bullet points here,
but monitoring is the key
because at this scale,
when you see in
generally, in hardware,
we tend to think that okay,
you need to get a repro.
All that's not going
to happen, right?
Like customers facing this issue,
you've got to figure it
out so we need to have
as much as monitoring alerts
and notifications
that we can have.
The failure rate has
remained quite low,
and we have some alerts for
that the RAM failing over
some time or some of
the parts that like
oscillators and stuff
like that failing.
So, we're kind of
monitoring that like what
the thing is for that.
I think, another thing
is like it's
a mindset change as
well because to work in
the co-exist in fashion between
hardware engineers and
software engineers
to build a team around that,
that had like initial challenges
to understand each
other, et cetera.
That is an iterative problem
that you resolve,
and the biggest benefit
that I saw of this one
on firsthand is
basically when we have
a new SDN feature that we
want to implement
in the software.
Earlier, when we started
off the software
existed and we figured out how
to offload the stuff to hardware.
So, that's the way we
were thinking, but now,
whenever we are doing
a software feature,
we say, okay how is hardware
able to support it?
Because we do have
a hardware limitations
in terms of tables et cetera.
So, that is also
another mind shift
that we see while doing
this entire project.
So, that's it. Any questions
or if I don't know
if you have time.
>> We have a question here.
>> Yeah.
>> I had a quick question
about migration.
It seems like there's
a lot of dependency
on the hardware and whatnot.
>> So, like live migration?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, so we do take that
into account and that
does mean at this point
of time to upload
the flows from the hardware
to the software,
because we need to save the state
of the VM as it is and
then migrate it out.
So, we will remove
the hardware offloads
at that point of time,
save the state, move
it and then re-enable
the hardware offloads
at destination.
>> Do you anticipate there to be
any scalability limits
with FPGAs as
we scale to even faster and
host networking say
400 gigabits per second,
maybe even 800
gigabits per second?
>> Yeah, we do see that.
Actually at this point of time,
the bottleneck is
the host because we still
have to do the first packet
processing in the host.
So, once the offloads
have been offloaded
to the hardware,
it is still able to
scale at that level
but we make continuous
improvements for example,
you also have a memory constraint
which is also a bottleneck
in that thing, right?
Because you have multiple flows.
You started out with
a single full-sized VM
and then you go down to
having multiple flows.
There is a limit
at the end of it,
and if any packet has to
get process in the host,
because of hardware limits,
that is a problem that
we have to look at it.
>> Yes, I guess
a following question,
do programmable A6 which is like
the barefoot switches
have the capability
to handle all the layers
here and also hit
the cost point as
an alternative when
the bandwidth scale up?
>> Right. Do you have
a question? I thought you said-.
>> Like the barefoot switches
programmable A6 switches
have the capabilities to handle
this as they scale
up and capacity to?
>> I am not aware but
one thing is we are doing
all this in the host.
So, that is something
that we have to
keep in mind like
we have to support
the host SDN because that's where
we try to do all the
policy enforcement.
>> Done?
Done. All right. Thank you